[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
well
we are going to talk
british politics today
trending
the british trump has resigned
but he didn't resign i i don't know how
this works you know
they have a little bit different
democracy than we do um over there and
how it works and how their elections are
run and
and actually triggered you know ours are
based on dates
but it seems as if boris johnson the
british trump
as it were as he were
is going to resign
his post is prime minister and
he's going to stick around for a while
so he can use the
checkers facility i think that's what
it's called i don't know
i don't know
the royalty thing um has always confused
me
i'm confused by it
like i i you know of course
growing up here in the states
we generally don't understand royalty
or
you know
the crown because we don't have or we're
not supposed to have one here
we're not supposed i mean that's what
the fascist wants that's what maga wants
that's what these trump pumping idiots
want is they want to have royalty here
i or so it seems
[Laughter]
uh white trash royalty
the trumps are i guess
the trailer park king
i don't know the point is
with the british politics we're going to
pretend like we're going to talk
british politics today no seriously it
is it is a big deal when a prime
minister of a world power especially one
of our allies like the uk
resigns um they've been calling for his
resignation for a long time
this seems to be
something that's been playing out for
quite some time
right i mean
i
over the last few days
his entire government has been resigning
out from underneath him and they've been
trying to replace him apparently but
they can't you know they just haven't
been able to replace him he doesn't have
a government
and so they called for his regulation
the funny part is is uh on rupert
murdoch's fox news this morning on fox
and friends
they describe oh yeah boris johnson he's
finished he's been done
his government he should have left he
should have left weeks ago
when his government was resigning
that fool kind of you know that's kind
of the attitude right
well what about your orange dd
[ __ ]
after january 6 they were all resigning
resign resign resign resign
because they knew what the [ __ ] they
knew the writing on the wall they knew
what he was trying to do he's trying to
overthrow the united states government
and they wanted to be able to say well i
resigned i'm a patriot
i mean even betsy devos
barely devos as i call her she's barely
the boss she barely was the education
secretary
barely devos even resigned
she couldn't even stomach it are you
[ __ ] [ __ ] me
when you lose betsy devos whoosh
whoosh
but you guys remember after january 6
one after the other the dominoes fell he
didn't he didn't have a cabinet really
trump that's who i'm talking not boris
johnson but this morning on fox and
friends if you take the clip where
they're talking about it you just
replace
the pictures of
boris johnson with trump and you're like
you [ __ ] boneheads where where were
you
right after january 6
you were still defending him then
and they're still defending him now how
it wasn't an insurrection
there wasn't violence well i think we're
gonna find out tuesday how much violence
there was in our country
but it doesn't seem to be
violence in the uk
no one's
storming
storming their government trying to
overturn it
they've just been calling for his
resignation
and eventually he [ __ ] resides
because he's you know
they don't like him he's worthless
he is kind of the british trump right
i mean all the way down to the [ __ ]
hairdo i mean it's not the same hairdo
it just
you know
it's what makes them stand out i guess
you could say
so the british trump resigns
as part of the news uh some other other
news and
in foreign land
uh brittany griner we talked about
brittany griner yesterday i guess she
pled guilty uh to drug possession and
smuggling charges
i don't know if this is smart or what if
this is part of some deal that they're
making apparently yesterday the
president vice president spoke with
brittany greiner's wife
and reassured
her that they were working on getting
brittany back to the united states and i
think it's
um something that needs to be done
i think all of us americans can get
behind getting brittany griner back to
the united states
apparently uh
it has to do with cannabis oil
uh that was packed in her bag uh i was
reading an article this morning from the
associated press
and it seems as if she is saying she
didn't intend to break the law
and she packed her bag too fast and had
this in there or didn't take it out one
of the other i'm not sure
so she pled guilty uh to drug possession
and smuggling charges in russia
which on its face sounds very dangerous
to plead guilty to anything but
apparently in russia
when you're when you're charged in
criminal court there's not
there's not much way out of it
and they're going to convict you and
they're going to jail you so
we'll see what happens there hopefully
um hopefully that
hopefully brittany griner makes it back
to the united states that would be a
huge victory
for our country for brittany greiner her
family
and even in the effort
to
try and
get russia under control here it's still
kind of ridiculous and we're still doing
this we showed a video yesterday of
vladimir putin speaking of russian
russia or foreign leaders vladimir putin
he looks he looks he looks like [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
he that guy looks like [ __ ] [ __ ]
i mean have you noticed that god damn
that guy's not i thought it was a body
double seriously in the video when i
first watched it i'm like is that really
him
but but apparently it is him
and he looks like [ __ ] [ __ ] now some
people have said in the comments since i
brought that up the other day um they've
said that uh
he's bloated because possibly he's
receiving cancer treatments and i i
don't
i don't um you know i'm not an
oncologist so i don't know anything
about uh cancer treatments or how it
affects the way you look
but uh maybe or maybe not but apparently
the guy is is sick
he's sick in the [ __ ] head
i mean i've always hoped that he would
eat an ammo sandwich for lunch you know
this guy's clock is ticking here
but it's not doesn't seem to be ticking
long enough we we there was a video
yesterday and maybe i can find it too
where russian state tv
they're they're seemed a little skitsy
they're even talking about whether they
would uh
appoint trump again or some [ __ ]
like they have a magic wand to tell us
who our [ __ ] president is
you know that's their propaganda there
they've adopted this propaganda that
they get to select our presidents as if
they selected trump and biden whoever
as if they have that power
i don't know
we we may be able to find that video
um i have also today an interview for
you now it's a great interview you guys
have seen dakota adams on our show
before
dakota adams is the estranged son
of the oath keepers founder stewart
rhodes you guys know stuart rhodes is
the the founder and the leader of the
oath keepers he's the one that had the
the authority over the qrf the stash of
weapons that were across the potomac on
january 6
he led his oath keepers
into the capital
where it appears that he was trying to
communicate with the president united
states to see if there was martial law
so they could take over the capital and
start arresting people
we're going to find out more about this
on tuesday i believe tuesday's hearing
is going to feature the proud boys and
the oath keepers
in the hearing and what actually
happened and took place uh on the lead
up to january 6 and january 6 and even
after that um to show that they were
intending
to incite violence and to use violence
to overthrow our government i think
that's what we're going to find on
tuesday and speaking of that go go make
sure sometime today now the link is
going to be going around twitter but
make sure to go to midas touch
youtube channel we'll be covering
the hearing
an hour before gavel of gavel and an
hour after
now these hearings are
are set to change at any moment so uh
bear with us as we try to keep up with
the announcements
so if there's more hearings next week we
will try to announce those to give you
the times and the links
so be paying attention to that uh you
can follow us here on our youtube
channel as well
make sure you keep up with all the news
at the tony michael's podcast
you can also follow us on twitter you'll
find all those links there at toni
michael's pod and then i retweet them
gabe retweets them um so they're there
and they're not they're not fake so we
will we will retweet them they're not
they're not satire or parody i'm going
to get to that too
uh
someone unnamed
uh did a big big instagram live last
night about and he's how he's an expert
on satire and parody anyways back to the
interview
i got off track there we have an
interview today with dakota adams
stewart rhodes
the founder of the oath keeper his
estranged son now normally
we talk to dakota about uh the proud
boys the oath keepers the militia uh
january 6 the lead up uh stuart rhodes
and his mindset
because he knows stuart very well
but because dakota adams grew up in this
militia type culture
um he also
because he was a
a teenager
that was
um on the fringes of society
he
he would
get on the deep deep dark parts of the
web like 4chan it ain't chan
um and having
knowing now what we know about the
shooter in highland park
ultra maga rooftop shooter
there's a lot of debate
of what this guy
his ideology is right what his political
beliefs were it's pretty clear who he
supported but that doesn't necessarily
give you an idea i mean
if you're a trump supporter you're you
know you're a [ __ ] bonehead so
there's no telling if you even know what
your own ideology is at that point or
what your own beliefs are i mean these
people claim to be pro-life but debbie
lasco wants to [ __ ] shoot her
grandchildren and she says it on the
house floor
so it's hard to tell it's hard to tell
where these people are at on the
political spectrum
but we know he was a trump supporter his
father was a trump supporter but i
wanted dakota to really try to unpack
what it means
that these
men
these white men in particular
who seem to be on the fringes of society
if the deep dark internet is breeding
uh these mass shooters
it's not video games it's not weed fox
news it's not pot they're not smoking
pot and wanting to kill people jesus
christ you smoking up pot you barely
want to get off the [ __ ] couch
let alone you climb up on a rooftop you
[ __ ] dummies
it's not pot it's not video games it's
not porn
there's something that is being
interjected ideas that are being
interjected ideology that is being
interjected in these
these people's brains
and it's poisoning them now i'm not
saying that they're victims
um but i am saying that there's
something to this
and it's strategic and dakota kind of
explains it in our interview with him of
how this is strategic from the far right
uh he has witnessed it inside 4chan and
8chan these are the deep dark parts of
the web folks this isn't this isn't
twitter this isn't the [ __ ] the the
trumper that's in your twitter feed
saying stuff this is much darker this is
much deeper
and this is much more sinister vile
stuff that goes on
in 4chan hn and some of these uh far
right wing
places where they talk about this stuff
and dakota explains it very well in this
interview
uh because he's been in these in these
chat rooms he's watched it he even
explains at one point where they
actually do kind of like a reverse
psychology to get people stoked up
um in these chat rooms and in these
threads
and he kind of explains that as well how
they use
fake accounts how they use certain
things to trick people into believing
certain things and getting them
in the mind of fear
to push their ideology farther to the
right
i mean he believes that these these nazi
groups have and these far right wing
groups have infiltrated a lot of these
chat boards and it's not the people that
you would think you would think that oh
it's you know far right wingers
that start out in these in these rooms
but dakota explains it very well it's
not
it's not just people who already are far
far right wing
it's people who are on the fringe of
society
and it doesn't necessarily mean
your your your political views it could
be
your sexuality it could be
your gender
it could be all sorts of things that
make you it could be the things that you
like recreationally
there's all sorts of things that can put
an individual on the fringe quote
unquote on society
and when they gather up in a room and
these right wingers
dispose their ideology on these people
and use
use that these people are on the fringe
of society
it starts to really take hold in a group
form in these threads and he explains it
so well and that's why i wanted to have
dakota on when i when i first found out
that this highland shooter
was in some of these uh
weird places on on the internet i mean
obviously he had a social media presence
he had a youtube channel he had an
instagram page uh he had a twitter
account
but it was odd because he was making
different kinds of music uh he had he
had people who were following him as
fans for this music
it was it was very uh a strange not just
different music but it was a strange
following
in these places and dakota really kind
of un unpacks some of that for us and i
knew he would because dakota knows these
sorts of things from the experience that
he's having in his life um dakota is a
brilliant individual
and he knows militia and he knows the
far right wingers all too well because
he's been around them his whole life
he was raised by them
that's the reason why i think it's
very important to listen to someone like
dakota so we are going to have him today
we recorded the interview yesterday at a
time that was best for him so you will
it's a pre-recorded interview uh but we
will play it here at the bottom of the
hour so here in about 10 minutes we'll
play the interview with dakota which is
about 30 minutes long and then at the
top of the second hour at the top of the
second hour we will go through the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends
again there's a lot of news to get to
today and i'm sure stuff is gonna be
breaking along the way
again the prime minister the british
prime minister uk prime minister boris
johnson has resigned
as the conservative party leader he will
stay on until they find someone else to
replace him i guess a lot of people are
saying
it's because
he wants to use checkers i guess it's
called checkers is that what it's called
i don't know is anyone here in the chat
in the uk am i saying that right
checkers
it's uh what the hell is it how do you
spell it it's c h now let's see god damn
it
yeah damn it
it's ch something
right c and i think it's a q and a u and
i think i think you would pronounce it
checkers
like the game checkers right yeah it's
c-h-e-q-u
is that how you say it checkers
i believe that's how you say it and i
don't know what checkers is
everyone in the uk knows what it is
everyone knows what it is in the uk uh
we we are very unaware here especially
me you know hillbilly me you know being
from the country i have no idea what
checkers is in in
in the uk apparently it's some kind of
facility that now the government has or
or the i know i don't know
i don't know but apparently they're
going to throw a wedding party there
that's where the party was where they
partied um check yours check yours does
it check yours oh okay well let's check
yours checker checkers
sorry that's the hillbilly coming out of
me checkers
hell boris johnson's gonna go to the
checkers
i don't know
but apparently this is where they threw
the party and
where they had all the coveted stuff you
know and he went he went anyways where
they had the coveted restrictions and
that's what really [ __ ] set some of
this off that was that's what some
pissed some people off and we had some
of that stuff in our country here when
certain governors
and would go to places they remember
obama they had his big party
and uh and
matt knight says here i'm not alone so
matt must be a hillbilly too i don't
know maybe it's just that you're from
you're from the united states you just
you just don't know i i just don't know
i'm just ignorant of the of the areas in
the uk i i i'll admit it i'll admit it
cut it clip it just the words i'm
ignorant there you go anyone who wants
to clip that you can clip it and put it
out on the internet
uh anyway
anyways uh
i i think this you know we had this back
and forth about coven a couple of the
governors would go to parties obama
through a big um
party and you know you had to have your
vaccine you had to be tested you had a
certain protocol to make sure no one got
covered you know i don't know if this is
the same over there but he got pissed
off
um this guy and boris johnson he may or
may not have handled uh coded well over
there and
we didn't handle it well in this country
because we had
uh
we had
dumb [ __ ] captain [ __ ] as our
president at the time
so you know it goes without saying that
we could have done better i think the uk
could have done better but when you have
trump and british trump in charge of
things during a pandemic it doesn't bode
well hello [ __ ]
but anyways british trump
is quitting but he's not quitting yet he
will quit
and resign later the other news the
other news that i want to get to in the
[ __ ] list roundup is this elon musk
stuff
have you heard this
elon musk and herschel walker have a lot
in common apparently
yeah they have a lot in common they got
all kinds of kids everywhere i don't
know what the [ __ ] going on
you would think the republican party
who's about family values and they
always talk about how oh fatherless
children and all this nonsense all this
[ __ ] you think you think they would
be really against herschel walker and
elon musk
you would think but they're not the
other news that i want to bring up uh
real quick
and i think i think this is uh
very very great this is great uh
rosalind carter and president jimmy
carter have been marrying for i think 76
years
76 years they've been married holy [ __ ]
congratulations to
uh president carter and his wife
rosalind carter for 76 years i believe
it's 76 75 76 that's a long time
holy [ __ ]
congratulations uh to them
congratulations to the carters so and
we'll talk about that in the [ __ ] list
roundup but right now we are gonna go
to the interview with dakota adams so
stick around the interview will be right
after this break
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
i've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever i try it never
sticks so when babel made a mag edition
i knew i had to give it a try babble
maggot edition makes it really easy to
learn and there's lots of lessons to
choose from like subtly racist to
full-blown white supremacists the first
lesson began with learning simple
phrases and soon i was putting those
words and phrases into a conversation
each lesson takes about 10 to 15 minutes
to complete and they're all really
different which keeps things interesting
the app is really smart it actually
keeps track of the words that i'm
struggling with i chose babel mag
edition because it's created by smart
white people like me and now i can't
wait to explore meet new friends and use
my new maga skills with my in-laws all
lives matter
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome back to the show thanks for
joining us we have a special guest with
us here today dakota adams a reoccurring
guest on the show as a matter of fact um
normally we talk to dakota about proud
boys oath keepers militia having to do
with january 6 but today i wanted to
bring him on to get his take because he
he has seen
this stuff before with the militias and
4chan 8chan some of these deep dark
parts of the web we know
now who the highland park shooter is um
he had a social media presence and an
online presence which i don't know if
that's a good or bad thing i hope
dakota's can kind of give us an idea
here of how that played into who they
are trying to make him into be and out
to be uh dakota welcome thank you for
joining us uh for having a quick
conversation about this what did you
think when you when you um heard who the
highland park shooter was and when you
started to
you know dive into some of this
information about him who he was his
online presence what was your first
thoughts
well first of all in an ideal world we
would be able to shut down information
about these people because a serious
part of the problem
is
the very fast easy pipeline of mass
murderer to
instant internet celebrity especially in
uh darker anonymous internet communities
and where we have uh mass shooters
inspired by each other's manifestos in a
chain and we saw that a lot with the
people inspired by dylan roof
unfortunately we don't live in a world
where
we can reasonably tamp down on these
people's five minutes of fame
and keep that from happening because we
have
in general a media punditry machine that
feeds off of
any interesting information about
tragedies and exaggerates it for click
value and then also we have political
machines in place
that will grab
any
noise they possibly can out of any
situation to deflect their side from
being blamed and that's what we have
here
and the thing that struck me first of
all
was that the right wing was going to
make immediate hay out of this guy's
basic physical appearance having
being skinny having facial piercings
having dyed blue hair in some of his
photos those are characteristics
that are possessed by people all over
the political spectrum but you know
that your great uncle on parlor is going
to run with that as a sure sign that
he's antifa from the beginning uh
wearing black clothes or having a black
face mask in any photo means that anyone
who does a bad thing is automatically
and antifa operative
and that was immediately going to be the
narrative that was seized but
really no matter what happened they were
going to seize the narrative of it being
a secret
uh leftist provocateur no matter what
and so the main striking things
about this case are the
history of violence threats of violence
uh flagged in school that resulted in
being in him being pulled out of school
the police showing up and seizing knives
and swords from his house after he
threatened to kill members of his family
and then immediately afterwards his uh
trumpster one of the politician father
helped him
get a
go through the application for
purchasing firearms
like within months of the police seizing
knives from his home because he was
threatening to murder everyone so what
we have is a failure
in the family and familiarly
someone who should have been caught
in the red flag net that slipped past
because the system fundamentally is not
working
and
beyond that we see that this is again
he had previously attempted to break
into a synagogue and was turned away by
security in that same area which is
known for being a predominantly jewish
area
in this uh outlying community of chicago
and
that while not explicitly neo-nazi a lot
of the chat rooms he hung out win were
very racist
and that's where we have this larger
trend
of reactionary and accelerationist
thought that
is feeding into the background media
noise that is driving
in my opinion a lot of these shootings
this idea that western society is
inherently broken
because or degenerate because
basic tenants of liberalism like
free speech democracy tolerance
especially tolerance for
uh the queer community or minority
ethnic groups is being conflated
with everything that is wrong with the
neoliberal global order including loss
of jobs from outsourcing and
environmental degradation like it's just
a common thread from extremist muslim
groups to the reactionary right wing is
the conflation of so-called
degenerate
social practices which is really just
basic human decency
with everything that is wrong with the
world economic order and how it has
disadvantaged the poor in the middle
class
and so you have
this general sense
of this vague straw man of
liberalism and secularism
and tolerance catching blame for
everything that is wrong with your life
that is making your life suck so you
don't have to claim responsibility
or do the research on figuring out what
harmful systems are actually causing
your life to suck
and in this you have a lot of people
that are just very much on the fringes
of society that are already prone to
violent ideation
that are prone to anti-social behavior
that see this larger internet community
where
violence against society
is celebrated
because anything that causes chaos and
accelerates the collapse of society is
inherently good because our current
society is inherently sick and evil and
it's going to draw people
who just
want to be celebrated for being an edge
lord and provides them fuel
for
violent thought and antisocial behavior
and shows them
mass shooters
especially racist mass shooters being
celebrated just for going against
the grain
and that i think is
the real story here and you also have
him being involved in a bunch of niche
internet communities being a soundcloud
rapper having a hyper pop album being
involved in what people are calling the
nazi cat boy
internet social circle so you're going
to have people dragging furries into all
into all this as if it's relevant wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait you said
internet cat boy internet not t-cap but
what do you mean what does that mean i
don't know what that means tell me what
that means so you have this interesting
phenomenon going which i call the uh
social experiment petri dish from hell
is this is this like a marjorie taylor
green petri dish type thing or is this a
a a petri dish not a peach tree dish
what is it
okay um could be could be both probably
because a lot of people in it have no
idea what a petri dish is okay i
apparently don't because i misspell it
on twitter but the and this is something
that's been going on for a long time is
that in the heyday of early anonymous
internet communities when 4chan culture
began to coalesce and form
these places were a catch-all for
everyone who did not fit into mainstream
society and that meant lots of people
with french political views
uh people
espousing racist views from the safety
of anonymity before that was allowed in
the mainstream
and it meant a lot of queer youth and
gender non-conforming people who were
trans or non-binary or simply expressed
themselves differently in a time when
there was no mainstreamed
or even
semi-well-known uh subculture for them
to participate in all in the same
melting pot
and then that melting pot of young
people especially young men
who were
on the fringes of society and felt like
outcasts was deliberately targeted by
white supremacists and violent fascist
groups
the for recruitment and to be made into
a pipeline the most famous example is
the now very very well known
um stormfront attempt that was highly
successful at taking over large chunks
of the different 4chan communities to
turn them into white supremacist
recruiting pipelines
and in that catch-all they got everyone
who was on the fringe so you had
the early forerunners of
people who are now
called femboys just
men who do not consider themselves
transsexual
who
just
enjoy
exhibiting
feminine personality or body language
traits and dressing in feminine clothing
because they feel it
fits who they are more and there's a
subculture for it but because of that
early exposure
through these melting pot online
communities to vicious very well
coordinated white supremacist pipelines
a lot of them were exposed to racist and
fascist ideologies where you have
nazi uh
gender non-conforming and cross-dressing
communities that have tremendous overlap
with other
somewhat marginalized primarily online
subcultures like
furry communities it's kind of a
knock-on effect
of the attempted nazi takeover of the
punk scene from way back in the day
anywhere where you have a gathering of
generally anti-authoritarian
non-conformist outcasts forming their
own culture
nazis will see that try to co-opt it
and attempt to build up their brand
inside that community and this is no
different
and the follow-on to that is that people
are going to seize on
dressing in women's clothing and wearing
cat ears
and
having a cat girl profile picture for
your crappy hyper pop albums
and they're going to grab on to that
especially in media
because it's quirky and unusual and
interesting to the majority of
mainstream normie internet goers and
casual twitter consumers who are not
aware of any
of those subcultures
and they're going to seize onto that and
in doing so further
the
perception of
all of these niche communities as being
nazi adjacent and facilitate their
capture as nazi branding
when the real story should be
that
these young men who feel like they're
marginalized who have crap lives who
probably have very toxic abusive homes
judging by the number of people online
saying that his father was widely hated
and frequently kicked out of local bars
they are falling into internet
communities that celebrate mass violence
as an ultimate statement against society
and also propagate
racist and fascist ideology and imagery
and the subcultures that he was a part
of
in parallel to that are less important
than the widespread dragnet
of violent ideology that is meant to
grab all of these young men
who fall in that same category who fall
into
steve bannon's uh much
beloved target demographic of
rootless white males
and inspire them two acts of violence to
strike back against society and become
famous even if only in their internet
circles
that's the real problem but everyone's
going to fixate on the cat ear headband
and the women's clothing the media is
going to run with that and obfuscate the
real issue right so they're not going to
get to the heart of why why they're even
reporting on some of these issues like
they like they like they should be
and that's why i wanted to have you on
because
when when this first started happening
me and gabe were texting back and forth
because i went to the social media to
try to see what who this was and what it
was i was actually trying to
grab some of the videos that he had
posted because my one thought was is oh
my god someone's going to take these
videos and they're going to turn them
into whatever they want and their
because these videos are going to be
taken down is what i thought i guess
youtube and some of this other content
and they're going to make it into what
they want and start spreading around
these deep dark webs gabe sent me an
actual screenshot of 4chan i believe it
was won the game yeah yeah
like he sent me a screenshot of 4chan of
of what was happening right in real time
and i was like holy actual [ __ ] like
they were already all over the
narratives that you're talking about
um and it's almost like
they turned on one of their own it
almost felt like that when you were
reading what they were saying about him
and then going to like uh his social
media and seeing some of the things he
had said some things he'd done like whoa
it almost feels like
they're saying he isn't one of us
anymore
and and then scapegoating all those
things that you're saying that list of
things that you're saying whether it's
the women's clothing these are the cat
ears um because you said you said um
so smartly the punk scene and how the
nazis took over the punk scene because
it's almost like tried to that's the
thing is it wasn't quite successful
because they got their asses kicked
which is a lesson we need to relearn in
this year of our lord
right well but i guess my my question is
is that what what
the real story that you're saying that
the media is not going to pay attention
to because i want to pay attention to it
is what can't what is there anything
that can be done to undo some of this
online culture where where it is this
like you said dragnet where they just
try to rope in as many people as they
can to get them to listen to their
ideology right and they know that some
are gonna believe it some aren't but the
ones that they rope in now they're part
of the the team as it were so is there
anything that anyone can do is it is it
paying attention to it is it actually
knowing that it exists because i think
that's the one thing i've had a lot of
hugely important right well i've had a
lot of normal trumpers you know the guys
like the fat guys and the trump t-shirts
and the trump hats like this guy this
and and and the boots and the blue jeans
and you know their their bellies hanging
out and they're like this guy
he got colored hair he ain't the trump
supporter there's no way he's drunk you
know i've had those like in my twitter
comments and i guess
they're not they're even even trump
supporters are very unaware that it's
not about the color of someone's hair or
where they grew up or or what body type
they are if they have tattoos on their
face or not um it really is about buying
into right wing authoritarian stuff and
i think even they're missing why like
the cubanon thing like you said nazis
try to grab onto this stuff like they i
believe they try to grab onto this q
anon thing and really run with it that's
why there's these these really
deep seeded roots of white supremacy
inside the q and on whatever the hell it
is right you know because they grab from
a lot of theories but
tell us what can we do do we pay
attention do we just ignore it because i
don't think that's the answer but no
just ignoring it is not the answer if we
could do concerted media blackouts and
stop
at least as far as not making these
people famous right and stop people from
like because that's the fantasy if
you're a bitter edgy loner
is
all these people go trawling through
your shitty drawings and your
terrible social media posts that never
got any likes while you were a nobody
and analyzing everything for meaning
like why did he do this what was his
ideology and that's plays into the
fantasy
but
we
cannot stop that at least not right now
right
the best
foot forward short of that
would be to start shutting down
right-wing media outlets that serve as
the entry point for the pipeline
that gets these kids into
like
environmental neo-nazism or great
replacement theory
where
i've seen people advocating for this and
i think it'd be a great tactic is
what the hell is that one guy's name
the every town
for gun violence no
the uh the guy who holds uh dnc funding
by the balls perpetually who's super
about assault soros
no actually the one who actually holds
dnc
uh bloomberg okay there you go oh right
yeah yeah yeah if we could get bloomberg
to help guarantee or some other of
these
liberal dark money billionaires that i
keep hearing about that seem to be
totally missing in action when anything
needs to get done
if they could guarantee get biden on the
phone because billionaires all have
presidential access we all know that
guarantee funding to the irs to
investigate the [ __ ] out of right-wing
media outlets for tax fraud
because i have no doubt that they've all
committed or at least the individual
pundits have you could probably shut
down
half of the right-wing media ecosystem
in about two years
if you took a really hard look at their
taxes and had the resources to go after
offenders
because the main problem is that very
large media companies are i believe
knowingly
serving as entryways into
right-wing extremist pipelines that lead
into accelerationism this idea that
society is inherently corrupt and
anything that collapses it faster is
inherently good so that it can be
replaced it leads into the great
replacement theory and white identity
they are knowingly serving as the entry
points
into information ecosystems that serve
stochastic terrorism that's the idea
that
you broadcast violent rhetoric
and rhetoric that implies that violence
is the only solution until somebody
picks up a gun and then you the
broadcaster
sitting in your comfortable house with
your high salary are comfortably well
insulated from the actual actions of the
shooter you have plausible deniability
and you can continue to signal boost
them in the ideology that created them
as a mass shooter so that somebody else
does it again it's a
fire and forget me medic form of
inspiring terrorism and controlling
narratives through mass shootings
short of shutting down right wing media
outlets
everybody needs to check on
the isolated teenage boys in their lives
because i
had a pretty disturbing close brush with
white supremacist recruiting pipelines
when i was a youth i was uh
when between our sporadic fits and
starts training for the apocalypse i was
effectively a neckbeard and then one day
all of the 4chan communities that i
frequented were flooded with violent
interracial um porn
by posters
badly role-playing as globe and black
nationalists who were celebrating the
cultural victory of black men over the
white establishment it was a transparent
attempt to get people to
knee-jerk into white identity
as
a
counter-reaction
and an instinctive swinging the other
way and then sure enough in the comments
people started posting like prototypical
versions of the
like those those uh edits of
world war ii nazi footage with little
dark age playing over the background is
the
popular music edited over nazi
propaganda from the 40s saying no don't
give in to despair uh the death of the
white race to miscegenation isn't is uh
not inevitable you can't listen to these
anti-white crowing voices and a ton of
people bought it even though it was the
most transparent thing in the world and
i think
my
lifelong training to see conspiracies in
every shadow actually helped me clock
that this was
a deliberately engineered
uh bait and switch recruiting tactic
by white supremacist groups organized on
stormfront which is exactly what it was
the chat logs leaked later
and
everyone whose teenage son was on 4chan
in that time was exposed to
violent white supremacist rhetoric that
was key to play on all of their
insecurities uh sexual societal
um your place in life your future as a
member of the middle class all play on
all these insecurities and then set up a
violent white supremacist ideology as
the natural counter-answer
then after that
going against all my instincts
of not being a snitch and not playing
into the information state
if you have that guy in your high school
who constantly makes
the mass shooting threats and draws the
edgy pictures
maybe you should make a report just to
establish paper trails because the
system is not in place
to
actually
address this right now is that one
common sense gun control effort that
would
gun safety effort that would make
the most impact for preventing mass
shootings is never properly implemented
and constantly handicapped
and wherever you can establish the paper
trail
to so that if someone does pop off you
can say look at this
there were warning signs here are the
receipts
it puts more actionable pressure on
people but honestly
it sort of feels like
all this
has a good chance of coming to nothing
the coming supreme court decision that
would allow state legislatures including
state legislatures that are
so thoroughly guaranteed that there is
no chance of anyone but a republican
holding the state house
allowing those state legislatures to
overturn the results of presidential
election and submit the votes however
they decide that's coming up next year
and the supreme court will effectively
mean the end of competitive
uh national
elections in this country
and the very next republican white house
will do everything they can not only to
destroy the electoral system but to
encourage stochastic terrorism like
we're talking about here
against all dissidents
and anyone that is against them ron
desantis will absolutely if he gains the
white house do everything he can
to dismantle any attempt at stopping
or
being aware of potential shooters
like the one
that
killed six people seven i believe now
yes yeah at highland park and injured 26
more
because it
is a time-tested
strategy to simply allow
non-state violence by your supporters
against dissidents to cement your
control
the debt squads
that fired on protesters after pinochet
took power
were not officially aligned with the
government the debt squads that slit the
throats of
democracy liberal activists in turkey
during the military coup attempt
were not killed by state security all
that happened was state security had to
stand idly by
so what we're facing now is
this rising tide
of
so-called individual
[Music]
lone wolf attacks
and mass shooters these young men will
be drawn in that are being drawn into
these pipelines
it's happening because they don't see
anyone fighting for
a better future
that will fix the problems that are
affecting them in their lives
in a way that they're aware of like the
the complete lack of action
by anyone except crazy right-wing
demagogues
at fixing
anything or advancing any kind of goal
is feeding into the idea that only this
will work only collapsing the system
will work and the people with the
histories of domestic violence
and murdering pets and threatening to
shoot at their school
will be the first to pick up their guns
because they're looking for an excuse to
lash out at society anyway and this
greater narrative driven
by the ongoing failure of our government
is simply feeding into that and so we
see now is this
environment of a failed society
being used to sweep up potential mass
shooters
and beta test the messaging for inciting
lethal violence against dissenters the
next time republicans control the
country
so what you're saying is is that if we
allow republicans to control our country
uh which maybe speak to the
pro-democracy message um that if uh uh
an actor and fascist actor like ron
desantis were to take power he would
turn the 4chan army against our
democracy i think is what you're saying
that's exactly what i'm saying and not
even the 4chan army just the guy in your
local gun store or who talks about
well right how we need to how we need to
kill people i guess
earlier which you know steve bannon
using world of warcraft and gamers to to
penetrate through and get them you know
i mean he even quoted in his book of
saying you know that he was able to
figure out a way to manipulate that he's
like you can activate that army you know
he was it's inspired by gamergate where
he saw
the minute there was something to
this directionless
rootless
society-wide anger
at
all of the entitlements promised to the
white middle class dissolving and
falling through
once you have a target because initially
there were people like the youtuber
totalbiscuit who did video game reviews
who were actually talking about ethics
and games journalism because he'd
received a attempts by video game
companies to effectively bribe him to
give good reviews of their games and
he's like so i think like people should
disclose when they have relationships
with game developers or game reviewers
in the interests of transparency
and then that was immediately seized on
as a funnel to pour all of this rootless
anger at society
for failing to deliver on all the
promises implicit in american media and
steve bannon saw that and he went i need
a way to harness this energy and that
feeds directly into the cambridge
analytical scandal where every tool of
the modern information economy
was utilized to develop and refine the
perfect targeted advertising and
algorithm-driven uh instruments of
delivery
for seizing on this online army turning
it into political action and eventually
into violence
and that is where if
the current gop gains power again
without a serious cleaning of house
all the violence that we are seeing will
have just been test runs for using the
media to incite
violence against anyone they disagree
with or against society in general
so that
local government
and the basic functioning of the nation
can collapse and they can assert
authority in a state of emergency in the
vacuum the entire gop playbook is about
destroying institutions
so they can say the institutions never
worked
and enforce their own private sector or
religious alternative under their
control
to fill the vacuum it's playing out
through everything from law enforcement
to education
this is no different
the more chaos the better because they
want to ride the wave
well thank you dakota for joining us and
please come back next week after the
hearing um there's going to be a hearing
and it sounds like
the proud boys and oath keepers may be a
uh
main point
in this upcoming hearing next week so if
you would please join us next week and
we can talk more what we usually talk
about which is the oath keepers and
proud boys but thanks for coming today
and giving us analysis of uh what the
deep dark web is creating uh where we
see some of these mass shooters um
coming out of the woodwork and not
knowing where they come from but we
should know where they possibly come
from if we would just pay attention a
little bit more and know what is at
stake
and don't get
don't get distracted by quirky
subcultures focus on what's really at
stake which is
the funnel that all anti-social
disaffected young men can fall into
when a massive media machine
is aimed at directing them into violent
social circles
well thank you dakota for joining us
come back very soon my friend thank you
very much thanks for joining us we'll
see you soon my friend thank you for
having me on
we'll be right back
mark 60 seconds this is the tony
michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capitol have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too hardened blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa
don't delay and get your part in blanket
today for just 99
actual parting's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for joining us through the
interview what a great interview with
dakota adams
really breaking down
for us there
giving you good insight and what i'm
going to do is i'm going to flip out
that interview and post it just by
itself on youtube that way you guys can
go watch just the interview if you want
to re-watch it or if you want to send it
to someone uh to re-watch the interview
there and we'll post that on our youtube
channel so don't forget to subscribe to
the youtube channel
the tony michaels podcast hit the
subscribe button
for more and more content you guys know
we we
broadcast live every single weekday noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific from
youtube twitter and twitch and we also
simulcast to the midas touch facebook
page
it looks like
there's talk we know that there's gonna
be a hearing on
tuesday now we just got done discussing
it with dakota adams uh hopefully he'll
be able to join us i'm hoping uh he'll
join us after the hearing to give us his
take on some of the things that they
actually the evidence that they uh bring
out against the oath keepers and the
proud boys i believe that's going to be
part of tuesday's hearing
that's what we're hearing so far
and there is some talk right now even on
twitter that it looks like tuesday and
thursday there's going to be hearings so
it looks like we're going to get at
least two hearings next week
some talk was at the very beginning that
thursday will be day eight
because remember when they first started
talking about this they said we'll
either have six to eight of them
now the assumption is maybe the eighth
one if it is the last one that might be
in prime time but we know tuesday's time
the hearing
starts at 10 a.m eastern time we will
start our coverage over on the midas
touch youtube channel so do not forget
to go over and subscribe to the midas
touch youtube channel
so that way you do not miss that
coverage on tuesday because we will
start our coverage at 9 00 a.m eastern
so if you're on the uh if you're on the
west coast it'll be very early if you
get up get your coffee get your popcorn
ready in the morning popcorn for
breakfast because it'll be 6 a.m then
our coverage will start on the midas
touch youtube channel
for the midas touch network now we will
be broadcasting with special guest and
commentary anywhere from the legal af
host uh to possibly uh mile coppola with
my michael cohen host michael cohen now
we've had texas paul and midas mighty
favorite
on now we've had ron reagan it's
possible we could bring ron reagan back
next week we have david bender political
strategist and my favorite political
strategist maybe i'll be able to get
rachel bittikoffer dr rachel bittikoffer
maybe next week to give us some
commentaries well we also have the trump
nda killer on our commentary panel
and then also
lee mcgowan the politics girl
from the politics girl podcast
you guys love these people minus money
loves these people and we're we're
excited next week to get back to the
hearings to really uh go through this
evidence and apparently and the january
6 committee
the select committee has received more
and more testimony even just in the
since the last hearing where cassidy
hutchinson as you know
she was testifying against trump's and
mark meadows
some of the salacious things were that
trump
threw ketchup against the wall and he
tried to assault the secret service
agents but the most important thing is
he knew these people were armed he
wanted them to go to the capitol he
wanted to go with him and he wanted to
be crowned king of the united states of
america and since those pieces of
testimony
have reached the public's ears more and
more people have
gone before the january 6 committee to
give their evidence yeah maybe maybe
maybe not to stave off some criminal
liability
let's see what our executive producer
and co-host thinks about next tuesday's
hearing yeah but we're hearing that
maybe it would be tuesday and thursday
we know tuesday sounds like a pretty
much a slam dunk guarantee at this point
right uh for coverage to start our
coverage will start at 9 00 a.m eastern
which you know you love getting up early
in the morning yeah no i i really enjoy
an early morning person right i mean
look i get up before the sun i always
every morning i say eat you
um no i
don't really prefer weight you know beds
you will be you will be with us for most
of the yeah yeah i'm sure i'm sure nap
time will be whenever the hearing is
yeah
basically basically it'll go into the
hearing it'll have i'll have a beer
oh i'll like sit on the couch and i'll
probably fall asleep you know just like
like so it's like a nap beer a nap
i used to have a shower beer do you ever
have a shower beer where you take a
shower oh yeah i know all the time
hey we gotta go we're going out like
better you know crush that beer whatever
and then you just bring them into the
shower you got one you've got one that
you're drinking as you're going in and
then you got one ready to go oh crack
open you got it you got it sitting on
the vanity as you're exactly yeah yeah
you're not [ __ ] around then no i mean
look there's no time to waste you gotta
go i guess not i guess not but you're
gonna have a nap beer after tuesday's
hearing yeah i think so i think with all
of these i'm just like man
what the [ __ ] like we know we know
things are are crazy and
insane in the reality of what was an
attempt of to happen
is way worse than what we thought right
like every time we find out we have an
idea of like oh yeah
we know this person or we kind of know
their role and we have a slight idea
but then you look at back at kathleen
hutchinson or you look at donahue or you
look at
uh angle or or
uh rusty bowers or anyone and you find
that these testimonies are way more
damning
than we thought right they're revealing
way more details
of this attempted coup from the election
or even before the election through
january 6. so
it's like you could expect the worst
like the worst thing and then be like oh
nope that was even worse like you know
well i think that's why so many people
are actually coming forward now
apparently they have uh all new
witnesses and all new testimony yeah and
it's probably not
new testimony in that they're giving
more and more evidence right it's
probably just backing up
evidence that they already have like we
already know or have an idea that this
happened and we're going to talk about
it and they're like oh actually i was
there and i can confirm that did in fact
happen you're like right you know why so
i i think i just want to say you know a
big thank you to cassidy hutchinson
because i think that she kind of opened
the floodgates there
um
to have more people come forward and
feel comfortable knowing
that you know one of their own already
did and they felt that they had well but
it may be that they feel uncomfortable
because one of the things that was
striking to me about her recorded
testimony not the actual live testimony
the recorded testimony is man she had
she had a binder and she had all her
information organized oh yeah this was
not a person who was like just trying to
think from memory she had all her notes
she had all the documents that she had
she knew exactly what happened she had
it right there in front of her um she
was ready to testify and i think that
probably make made sure that people out
there that had out information that
could back her up um they were like wow
she's got her [ __ ] together
if i don't get in there and and do
something about this it's possible that
i'll have criminal liability because we
watch as as mark meadows still
you know scoffs at this and other people
still scoff at this as if this is not
going to come down on top of them we we
it is it is inevitable at this point
well i mean you have jeffrey clark
getting his uh electronic devices seized
you have john eastwood getting his
devices and then we see this week that
those same
group of [ __ ] uh get subpoenaed
down in georgia for a grand jury for the
for the
for the actual
the actual fraud that happened in the
state of georgia from state charges
right
so that that may come um and a lot of
people assume that that's some of the
easiest charges to bring against some of
these criminals that were trying to
overthrow our democracy where they were
trying to overthrow george's vote and
the reason why is because i think
there's some fear that these people have
pocket pardons because there's a lot of
talk about pardons pardons
matt gats marjorie taylor green rudy
giuliani john eastman uh all these
people wanted pardons and there is no
evidence to say that they didn't get
pardoned yet right like that's the thing
that i'm waiting for is is there
evidence that shows that they didn't get
pardons or that they did get pocket
pardons and that may be why the
department of justice is being very
careful here because we really don't
know what those
we don't know how those pardons work
right like right we've never had this
event in history where a president would
preemptively or pardon someone before he
left secretly so that way if they were
charged with a crime they could use it
we know matt gatz was trying to seek
like a blanket pardon from now until
kingdom come right right like oh i can
commit crime all i want
maybe that's why that guy walks around
so confident
i'm just saying you might have a pocket
pardon i don't know he he very well
could have a pocket pardon it's one of
those things where it's like
you know
why would you need a pardon what did you
do wrong you know what what are you
admitting to right now like you're
clearly you're clearly asking for a
pardon because you believe you're guilty
or could be guilty or found guilty or
whatever or at fault for something
why don't you come up to the front of
the class and tell everyone
why you needed that pardon and what you
were so afraid of right right you know i
would want to know like if if
if it's on the record that you were
asking for pardons whether it's giuliani
saying well i didn't need a pardon at
that time or whatever his like two times
deleted tweet that was basically
admitting to asking for a pardon from
trump or you've got eastman or you've
got uh matt gates or archer taylor green
or any of those other you know fascist
uh seditionist people that were in the
coup
you gotta wonder like what were you guys
doing why did you guys feel afraid right
why did you feel it was necessary to ask
for a pardon you know if you think that
what you were doing was totally
justified by the the what was written in
the constitution and that you totally
believed in what you were doing to fight
the election and the results of the
election
then why feel guilty right it's just
like for the same reason why you see
proud boys and patriot front and all
those other [ __ ] cucks who hide their
faces if you really were proud and you
really believed in the [ __ ] that you
were doing and you didn't feel
embarrassed or the potential that you
would be revealed with your true
identity
you wouldn't be hiding your faces
exactly if you're so proud and so macho
then then don't hide your face right and
if you really believe that that the
election was stolen
100
then why would you
feel like you needed to get a pardon
right what were you trying to cover up
so um i i i have something that relates
to what you're talking about um you said
rudy giuliani and a fascist and people
revealing themselves in public because i
think what you're saying is some of
these people are afraid
of being shouted at and shouted down
yeah uh called out for what they are in
public or you know their maybe their
pissy little job is at risk because
people find out they're nazi
but here is a video this is oh this has
seen this yeah this is beautiful
this is a video um
now is this him campaigning for andrew
giuliani after he lost already that's
what i'm trying to figure out the
timeline here if this is before or after
or if they're just using the remaining
uh funds that they were given as right
to get brain contribution to go just
like
drive around and be like i'm still
giuliani and i'm still america's mayor
right well they're trying to repair
their image because you see here on the
truck that they're driving which is a
stupid [ __ ] trump truck right yeah
rudy giuliani has probably never
actually driven in one of these trucks
until he's had to act like he was
[ __ ] i mean
when in the video he gets up in the
trunk or in the truck of the of the car
and he has to step up and get in the
guy's a [ __ ] troll okay
he has to reach up get up there he looks
like he's probably already two three
feet off the ground when he's standing
by the door inside the car like right
but don't you think like in giuliani's
life living in new york city this guy
would want to ride around in a limo
right oh yeah not some kind of hillbilly
jacked up truck come on this is this is
all this is why don jr grew a beard and
wears flannel shirts right it's the same
[ __ ] to appropriate the [ __ ] the
culture so that they feel like oh yeah
this is the whole all the the um
blue collar building
yeah he's like i'm just like you i'm the
common man and he's like
he's like out of here hello my friend
it's like giuliani is an italian from
brooklyn he knows nothing about about
rural farmers he doesn't like a goddamn
thing it's like the scene from community
where steve buscemi comes in as like a
he's got a hat on and a hoodie and a
skateboard and he goes how do you do
fellow kids right that's what this is
it's these people trying to relate on a
level that isn't there it really it
really gets me because uh you know i
grew up in rural white america right and
so i'm i'm very familiar with that
culture
let me tell you something
people from rural white america don't
appreciate city folk acting like their
country they don't like it they had a
whole show on it it was called green
acres i don't know if you ever
saw the show green acres it's been a
long time ago
but
they did a whole show on it actually and
it just it it it gets me it gets me in
my crawl when people that
my whole life would look at rudy
giuliani
and there's nothing wrong with being
italian from brooklyn it's just
different like i don't know what it's
like to be from a city i have no clue no
clue i did not grow up in the city i
grew up on in a rural area i grew up on
a [ __ ] farm you know with chickens
and cows
i didn't grow up
in the city so it's different experience
so i but i don't understand
how these two things have [ __ ] and had
a baby where rudy giuliani
i'm serious where rudy giuliani is
driving around in this [ __ ] stupid
trump truck um acting like he's some
kind of country boy but watch this video
this is [ __ ] hilarious and whoever i
i think it's the people who are taking
the video who are actually uh yeah yeah
because i think it kind of he reveals
himself at the end yeah so but you see
here in the in the in this still image
here this is grandpa farty mcarty rudy
giuliani and this is his uh uh his test
tube what is left over from eric trump's
son uh andrew giuliani here but listen
listen to the beautiful noise that comes
from behind this camera it is glorious
good days regardless of how you're
destroying this country
and i bet you you like abortion
[Music]
you [ __ ] fascist piece of [ __ ]
oh it's not over folks it's not over the
beauty has just begun he
but he goes right after rudy giuliani
as he's getting in the truck here um you
know he makes sure to get the you're a
fascist piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] out before
rudy gets in the truck and shuts that
door then this guy really wants to make
sure rudy understands exactly in case
you didn't hear me
right right let me say it louder you
fascist piece of [ __ ]
it gets better it gets better the icing
hasn't even started to go on the cake
here yet
don't you care about our country that
flag right there is democracy democracy
is what it means
oh it just gets better and better i i
think i watched this like 12 times the
other day just it's good it never it
doesn't get old i i mean that's it it is
amazing uh we i mean more people should
do that [ __ ] right did the same people
that you know are blowing whistles in
front of marjory taylor green's face and
matt gates and they're running away you
know even though they said they won't
back down
um these are the same things we should
be doing for these people hold them
accountable yeah get out get loud make
them [ __ ] be uncomfortable like
they should be really [ __ ]
uncomfortable showing their [ __ ]
these [ __ ] nazis right our country
and our [ __ ] democracy should be
really [ __ ] scared to show their
[ __ ] faces in this country and and we
know who they are so we can [ __ ]
shout them down from across the street
this is [ __ ] ridiculous we need to
stop this nonsense where we we
oh well nazis have have rights too they
do have rights and we do too we can yell
and scream at you that you're a [ __ ]
fascist piece of [ __ ] because rudy
giuliani
is part of maga he is part of the
structure he is part of the structure
that wanted to decouple us from our vote
and take down our democracy he doesn't
give a [ __ ] he wanted a fascist dictator
in power so that he
he could do whatever he wanted because
that's the fact him [ __ ] rudy
giuliani was drunk with trump all the
time and they were talking about how
they were going to take over the [ __ ]
world with the ukraine [ __ ] the election
and on and on and on with georgia
arizona that's what all that [ __ ]
pressure was and i can't wait i can't
wait to watch that [ __ ] fat stupid
slob rudy giuliani grandpa farty mchardy
finally get the cold steel put around oh
yeah [ __ ] that guy
whether it's whether it's through the
january 6th committee and there's some
sort of recommendation or it is through
georgia itself
well i i think i think rudy giuliani has
a lot uh
he has a lot more exposure than just
georgia because this guy was going all
around the country trying to commit
fraud well remember he was calling
everyone like they were the expired car
insurance right the expired car warranty
he's like uh hey uh it's rudy giuliani
and he's like and jenna ellis and uh
we're just here to yeah and like you
hear like
um and they're like we're just uh here
to talk to you about the 2020 election
and the apparent widespread voter fraud
and then just like rusty bowers said
he's like and yet when we asked for
evidence they said they didn't have any
and they were just working on a theory
at the time right right well they rusty
bowers the the arizona house speaker
kept at a republican by the way yeah who
would still vote for trump which is
[ __ ] gross but they kept he kept
asking them give me the names give me
the name show me the list show me the
list show me the evidence and they never
could produce it because it was fraud
let's listen to how this guy handles
this fraud rudy giuliani yeah trees and
his pieces [ __ ]
you trees in his pieces of [ __ ] crazy
respect
you don't deserve respect and you've
done that
oh boy just music to my [ __ ] ears
gabe music to my [ __ ] ears it is uh i
love that guy no it's great yeah no i
mean like you know more people should
say stuff you know
when they see people on the street dude
they're every look it's not cancel
culture it is consequence culture that's
right you supported a coup you supported
a group that put into place certain
supreme court justices those supreme
court justices have now begun stripping
away the rights as women
uh they will become coming after people
who are part of the lgbtq community
they'll be coming after interracial uh
marriage and relationships they'll be
coming after the the way in which
state
run elections are done uh they're gonna
come after it all and look
i'm sorry to say but
you were the people that put these
people in power and there are
consequences right it's like
we cannot deny
newton's laws of physics here right for
every action there is an equal and
opposite reaction and right now
this is that reaction that is happening
and i'm sorry to say but if it's if you
find it negative
that's on you
you know it it is and you know i have a
great story and i wanted to tell it um
after the fourth of july
uh
we went to our fourth of july parade but
seeing what happened
uh in highland park i i figured it was
much more
newsworthy to cover that story than my
personal story but i actually
i had a great story at our fourth of
july parade um our parade was pretty
boring because it seemed to be just
politicians there wasn't a marching band
there was a few dance crews that played
music and they danced and that was very
cool that was that was fantastic it was
some of the best some of the best parts
of the parade and most of the the floats
that were for the politicians they
weren't even [ __ ] playing music of
course most of them republicans because
you know i live in missouri but there
was one in particular that stood out
and it stood out to my wife who was
sitting next to me and she decided to
say something um
we watched this trump truck very similar
to the one you just seen in the video
there come down the street and it had
the candidate's name on it but it had
let's go brandon all over this truck and
then this person i don't know how much i
know how many thousands of dollars this
[ __ ] idiot is spent to put let's go
brandon all over the truck thinking it's
a good political slogan right i mean it
could win
to put that vinyl wrap on it that's not
that's not cheap it's not cheap it's not
cheap so he's got a let's go brandon
alvarez truck we see him from you know
coming from down the street
and they get they get to where they're
in front of us and it was so sad because
either the candidate was driving or it
was the one person who was walking
handing out flyers that's how much
support this candidate which is not
surprising to see the [ __ ] that they
had posted on their truck even in an
area where i am
most people don't even buy into this
let's go brandon [ __ ] it's such a small
[ __ ] percentage of these people now
the truck stops the person's handing out
the flyers to the people on the curb
and the guy in the truck honks the horn
and he tries to start chanting with the
crowd let's go brandon and before he
even gets out the word brandon my wife
yells [ __ ] you
just really [ __ ] loud re i mean and
everyone she was like i'm not
i'm
you think i give no [ __ ] and have no
[ __ ] to give i'm not even close not even
close now she'd been to uh uh a a
reproductive rights protest the day
before she was already hyped up oh yeah
yeah yeah he was all ready to [ __ ] go
she's like look man i miss [ __ ] him yeah
[ __ ] you so she yells out [ __ ] you
and everyone turns and people start
laughing and everyone's kind of agreeing
yeah and the guy passing out the flyers
and i don't know if he was the candidate
or he was just helping the candidate
well he was passing up liars he and he
was kind of you know in front of us he's
pretty sweet
and he kind of looks up and he smiles
and kind of laughs at her and she points
at him she said no
i'm talking to you
[ __ ] you
and the guy in the truck he was so
discouraged he just kept he just at that
point he was like he turned off the car
and just walked yeah well he couldn't he
couldn't he couldn't get anyone to chant
i i really i was laughing so hard um you
know me i can't help but laugh but i i i
thought afterwards i'm like man i wish i
would have had it on video but the other
thing i wish i would have is got
everyone to start chanting [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you
[ __ ] you you know because this guy is
such a chucklehead yeah you can't even
get people to walk with him and support
it's
i mean it you know if you're if you're
still
some people in that party cannot
kind of read the room right they they
can't read the ketchup on the wall and
it it's
i think i i honestly think that's the
new saying it's like oh man well i'm i'm
reading the ketchup on the wall right
now and [ __ ] is [ __ ] okay
but you look at this right and you've
already got nazis co-opting the let's go
brandon slogan narrative and so when
that happens you either say yeah
this is us
but again most of those people that are
gonna say yeah this is us have the mask
on so they might be saying in private
much like a kkk member might have the
hood on and then you know in front of
everyone they might say something
different right or not something as
extreme right
but
it is that same thing where
you have to you have to figure out which
which people are willing to double down
on this narrative that has already been
taken over and has already been proven
right you've got nazi flags uh that were
over over the interstate that had let's
go brand on it right it was taken
within within you know a short amount of
time and so now
you have to figure out okay are you with
trump and let's go brandon or are you
not with trump right and you know what
is the what is the outcome if you say
you're not with trump right especially
if you're running for election you have
to figure out kind of
where to put your eggs in which basket
you know and most likely probably the
basket of deplorables but right well but
you know it is a um it is
an american thing
to make sure just like this gentleman
did with rudy giuliani and
uh my
my adorable wife did with
the let's go brandon nazi in the truck
you have to you have to you have to make
sure to
uh
make them feel the shame that they
should feel right like because that's
the problem is they don't really feel it
quite yet they still feel like they have
a place in our society they have a place
in our democracy
and they may with their ideas because we
are a democracy and we are for liberty
and you get to have your views but like
you said you do not get to live without
the consequences of those views this is
not a cancer culture it's a consequence
culture and there are consequences for
not only your thoughts but your actions
as well right and if you if you make
your thoughts into actions you will pay
a heavy price and we should make them
pay a heavy price um
speaking of uh paying prices for actions
um you you are our headline today is
that
boris johnson has really
kind of resigned
yeah well yeah i mean when i went to bed
i went to bed at so it would be for your
time i was a i probably want to bed
around two in the morning uh okay
and
at that time the announcement had just
come out right right because because
it's across the pond so that's right all
right exactly right here ahead you know
and like all the cameras were waiting
for him to come out so i was like all
right well he's gonna resign
so i was like oh this is gonna happen
you know but it's there is a little bit
of it it's like i'm gonna i'm gonna
resign but i'll stay
as kind of the what did they call the
not the party leader but
it was kind of like a not like like a
liaison or right right right i'm going
to stay on until they find someone but
it sounds like he's supposed to throw a
big party i i think the place is called
checkers or check yours something like
that
like checkers like in the
u.s i know what i don't know you don't
have chocolates checker is the right the
the fast food restaurant
i don't think i don't think there's many
i don't know i don't i don't think
there's no i'm just saying it could be
checkers
it could be checked out right no it's
it's it's it's spelled differently okay
and apparently it's some kind of fancy
ass place over there in the uk i don't
know i don't know anything about the uk
really i was trying to [ __ ] fake that
i knew anything about british
that's fine
like i said all you got to do pinky up
grab something you know maybe do
anything you can see that's it well yeah
but but the point the point is it seems
to me that he's hanging on to have this
party is what people oh yeah yeah yeah i
mean here's the thing like when has
there not been controversy for boris
johnson right and the main reason that
there's controversy around boris johnson
and what ultimately led up to this kind
of forced resignation which by the way
his own conservative party pushed him
out all right like the uk did something
that
the us is unwilling to do right right
you have boris johnson and trump they
are the same person just different
hairdos
depending on order depending on how
windy the day is
right and
the uk is willing to push him out right
they're like oh [ __ ] this guy is [ __ ]
up [ __ ] we had brexit that [ __ ] up he
has all these [ __ ] uh controversies
right now he's got the you know which
again which is what led up to it is
chris pincher
um and led to a
a medley of just resignations uh of the
um ministers which are the kind of the
cabinet members in the uk those people
were like yeah [ __ ] this noise this is
we are way off the [ __ ] rocker
um for our party like you are making us
look like an idiot um and we need to get
you out you know we need to we need to
remove this this um
this poison right or or um this parasite
and we need to get rid of it so that we
can go back to what our core values are
the u.s on the other hand they're like
now let's see how much we can ride this
one right right right and like
we really wanna we really wanna we
really wanna embrace this parasite right
they're like even though
on in the u.s we were willing to say out
like after the impeachment we was like
yeah this was trump's fault and he
should have been impeached but we didn't
want to impeach him you know
uh even though he was twice impeached
this wasn't fully removed right um
when it came to the votes in the senate
but it is one of those things where it's
like wow the uk did something that the
u.s was unwilling to do right you know
it's like
i thought the idea you know not i mean
just like i thought the idea of the u.s
was to be better right you didn't want
to have this type of rule of law you
didn't want to have this type of way of
life and yet now
you're going back or you're trying to
form a different form of government and
have a different rule of law than what
you originally founded for these this
country and our founding fathers right
um but it i i think it says a lot that
you know they're willing to be like well
man we got rid of our [ __ ] trump when
we could right and that's what happened
they pushed him out and they're like
yeah we'll keep you around for right now
but like we're gonna get someone else in
well probably someone else would be more
conservative and more kind of like
straight and arrow and not so crazy but
you know they're pushing them out here's
here's fox and friends take on this
this morning of boris johnson being
called to resign of course you know fox
has a difficult time with boris because
like you said he is trump but he's not
always like trump right in in the in in
the respect of maga right yeah yeah like
he's not like maga would like him but
they would definitely eric greitens
would want to rhino hunt him right like
for sure like if boris johnson was in
the us if he was a politician in the us
but so they have a difficult time with
him but listen to how they describe why
he should have left just listen very
carefully it's [ __ ] hilarious
what has happened over the last
you know number of months and years is
the british people did not trust him he
would say one thing and would do
something else and then pop up in the
tabloids uh and then with this thing
it's a question of integrity he has
refused to go even though people have
been calling for him to uh hit the
pavement for a while because he would
say look i had a a mandate i had an
additional 14 million votes from voters
who voted for me in 2019 so i'm going to
stick around and he stuck around until
he saw the writing on the wall 53
government officials called it quits uh
the government of the united kingdom and
of england was in dire needs of somebody
to run different cabinet positions and
things like that
and so
his uh apparently his assistants were
trying to fill the positions as quickly
as people would quit but they couldn't
and they were people who were in charge
of security the courts technology
education finance northern ireland and
science so clearly
that's a lot of the government with
nobody running it and so now he's going
to leave and without a doubt his
problems
you can almost take the pictures of
boris johnson i text you this one you
can almost take the pictures of boris
johnson out of this and put in pictures
of trump like right after january 6
right and be like what the [ __ ] i mean
where were you at where were you at
and then in this in this uh peter
ducey's dead
yeah yeah yeah that's that's ducey
senior oh so this is dumb [ __ ] ducey
senior yeah
and where's jin saki when you need her
but but this is really fun you know you
take a few of the words out you put
pictures of trump up yeah instead of
pictures of boris johnson oh yeah i
think it totally works yeah we can
rework a video well i mean it's it well
i don't want to i don't want to piss
anyone off with satire now oh
is for the sake of comedy and making
people laugh
and realize what the [ __ ] fox is saying
i really i would not want to piss off it
would be already or satire expert yeah
yeah well satire and parody you know
just comedy professor
oh okay yeah yeah is he is he a
professor or a connoisseur of comedy i
don't know everyone knows it's hard to
say i'm i'm i'm
but i'm just uh i'm a taco connoisseur
so i who right right
right well i mean and you're so
unserious gabe that you're a really good
guy and you're really funny but you're
not funny and you're dangerous but
you're really funny you know it's it's
kind of a cool thing that you
yeah
as everyone knows yesterday yeah
yesterday well the day before
yeah
the night before right it may or may not
have
uh snuck into mar-a-lago and convinced
trump to release a a truth or a
statement on true social and then gabe
screenshot it and put it up on his
account um
uh
and you didn't properly market and it
really confused people that's the point
is to confuse you whether it's real or
not that's the point of satire political
satire in particular uh and there's one
uh blue checked account that really
didn't understand that and he kept
digging a hole yesterday yeah because he
didn't understand that and all so much
so that last night how long was that
[ __ ]
uh someone sent me a thing saying he was
live yeah yeah so yeah
yeah yeah because i because somebody
sent it to me and they said they said
he's doing a live about you and what
happened today it was like an hour long
and it was him trying to justify an hour
it had to have been more than an hour
because
when i when i went on there he's
probably watching right now
seth if you are watching if you watch
the entire show for us to talk about you
for three or four minutes to you know
make you feel relevant here on the tony
michaels broadcast uh as a as a satire
and comedy and parody expert which
you're not [ __ ] but if you're out
there listening you are more than
welcome to come on the show and i will i
will tell you and explain to you
whether you're an attorney or you got
phds or whatever the [ __ ] how smart you
think you are i will explain to you
exactly what our goal was because we
talked at yesterday we talked about
every time you release a statement every
time we do this stuff i'll explain to
you exactly what our goal is i'll
explain exactly what we're thinking and
there's nothing to hide it was obvious
what we were trying to do it's always
obvious what we're trying to do we don't
try to hide anything yes yes did we try
to fool people that's the point of the
parody or the satire excuse me um but
the point is is that he went on and on
and on last night and he tried to sound
smart he tried to sound educated he
tried to what he tried to do was he
tried to make a lot of historical
references to satire and parody to
explain to us
what
satire and parody israel is like is it
satire is it parody like parody you're
along for the truth you know you're
along for the trip right you're making
fun of this thing if satire you're
making a critique right yes like if
you know
well what what he was saying is that is
in in the in the live as he was saying
kind of two different things because
what he was saying is that satire parody
it's obvious satire it's not obvious and
we were saying yesterday one thing on
the podcast and not nothing i'm like and
he's and and someone in the comments was
challenging him actually several people
were challenging about what he was
saying and and he said no i went and
watched the show which he didn't watch
the show he said he watched he said
he was a viewer he came in and he
watched the first few minutes of the
show okay and he was like i listened to
tony michaels and he was talking about
how it was intentional and this and that
and he's like you know and
like his argument that he's trying to
make is that this whole thing was
misinformation right the thing that he
got stuck up on now the whole reason we
made it was because and again
any time you know i've made i've made
probably four or five
since 2020 right i've made you know
three this year
those three have gone viral and whether
that's just because people believe them
to be real or my account has a certain
reach or whatever it is
he said yesterday
that it was misinformation right but
again the reason
the purpose of this this announcement
was to focus on how trivial because
these are all of these things have
happened are all trivial in nature trump
is going to be upset that somebody said
he wouldn't have him on the podcast
it's so dumb it is so incredibly dumb we
know how much of a knucklehead or a
[ __ ] that trump is right
but for someone who is an adult for
someone who sits at home in mar-a-lago
the only thing he can do is is get
flustered because somebody said oh no no
no i i'm not going to give that guy an
opportunity i don't want to give him a
platform i don't want to i don't want to
i don't want him i don't know i don't
know
you know that yesterday
right exactly so that's what the
commentary was now he got tricked up on
the last part of the statement which was
[Laughter]
uh when we said you know he'd rather
have joe rogan would rather have a
second
uh rate
president
gutless ron desantis on his show instead
of me you know so that's what it was he
was like oh no no this is newsworthy
stuff this is something that journalists
all journalists like myself found
incredibly newsworthy the problem with
that argument
is that
nobody ever thought to cover it nobody
ever thought to look into it or if they
did they're like oh one this is dumb ugh
i don't really care for it or like this
is so dumb
like it's comical
and the the last part is them saying
who cares right well right i mean cares
it's not newsworthy especially over
someone who said i don't want this guy
on the on the podcast and that is what
seth is so upset about but the real i'll
let you go and then i'll explain kind of
where the the time for anyone who's
watching the timeline of events that
went down yesterday and what happened
but well yeah but because what he's
saying is is that
that it's not newsworth he claims to be
a journalist i don't know if he is or
not right [ __ ] i don't know it's hard to
tell from when you google seth abramson
if he's a [ __ ] journalist or not some
people say he is he claims he is he's a
self-proclaimed journalist gabe just
like you're a self-proclaimed satirist
but he may be a journalist but here's
the thing
and you're going to explain this in
timeline he's [ __ ] butt hurt because
he posted it someone challenged him
because if he's such a [ __ ]
journalist he didn't do his goddamn job
to go just go to true social that's it
it's we weren't it wasn't like we were
[ __ ] he kept saying we created a
document this wasn't a [ __ ] fake
email that we created between trump and
brogan or some [ __ ] this was a [ __ ]
public post that that and and the other
thing seth is you keep focusing on the
image that we made it looks so real the
part that's the [ __ ] satire is the
words
not the [ __ ] image dummy it's the
[ __ ] words is the satire read the
[ __ ] words
is what i have a problem with right and
and the other thing too is for him to
attack it for him as a blue checked
account with his fake really big
following that he has um that's right
right part of his following is not real
yeah but seth abramson
seth amundsen uses his blue check
account to come attack you who are not
you are not a blue chick
and
and
that
obviously does satire if you just look
at your [ __ ]
the top of your twitter for more than
two goddamn seconds then he claims oh
well they tried to really pimp it out by
using the podcast account yeah we
clearly did it was a coordinated effort
we wanted people to see it because i
don't know we made it it was satire we
wanted people to see it and some people
most people in the comments did not
believe this [ __ ] was real they didn't
believe it was real and they they
questioned that's the whole point that's
the whole point is they question holy
[ __ ] would he actually say something
like that trump would he actually say i
don't know i mean and then that is it
that is the unfortunate reality we've
lived in right now because we've set
kind of this new base
insane reality which is like this guy
could say something like that right like
this is so crazy that he would get upset
at something so trivial so dumb
some guy saying to the former president
right exactly nobody is covering this
you know outside of the fact of that joe
rogan is a voice and a personality and
he spoke up and said i'm not i'm not
going to bring him on i i've been asked
before and the only reason it was
newsworthy is because
it's because it's a president right and
because people are like oh we want trump
on the podcast that
whatever but at the end of the day it's
a non-issue it's not like i'm gonna
here's the thing again whenever i do
these it's always about something that
is so dumb
it's never about something that's super
important like oh [ __ ] he said this
thing about january 6 or oh [ __ ] he
talked about like killing someone or or
the death or whatever it might be right
that at the end of the day
it's about the most trivial
non-important dumb [ __ ] ever because
that is the commentary also that's being
made also to explain it all i feel is
like assuming someone
is not intelligent to be like hey just
you know disclaimer this is satire or or
this is parent like whatever it might be
like some things are more obvious right
right hey audience hey audience that we
want to give this to you're so stupid we
have to market we have to mark it as
period
or the fact that like he's like oh well
so many people were asking it's like
yeah well look i made it at night and i
went to bed and i [ __ ] woke up in the
morning
to a message that was from or a rather a
tweet of people saying
uh have you seen seth's uh page right
and i was like i don't know what you're
talking about like again i made it
didn't you know who the [ __ ] was
i made it i had my life i went to bed
right and then
it was yeah and i got a
[ __ ]
just a barrage of texts messages you
other people dms uh oh it was hilarious
and i was like
i woke up and i was like what the hell
is going on this is crazy
so then
throughout the day i'm like oh whatever
i'm dealing with other stuff we've got
projects going on the side that we're
working on we've got meetings
basically even tweet outside of just
like retweet people during the day
yesterday and i made a tweet and it was
a comical tweet to say hey i don't know
who the set guy is because i really
don't know who he is right i've never
spoken to him i've never really heard of
him before but i made a comment that
said i don't know who the seth guy is
but he apparently had a problem with
this parody kind of the spoof uh post
that i made
and then i said just in case and i was
like i think this could be a good
opportunity to let everyone know that
i'm not actually friends with don jr
again it's just a joke it's i'm i'm
discussing a separate thing to say like
in case you weren't sure this is me and
it's obvious that i'm not friends with
whoever uh you know i'm i'm not friends
with don jr so the timeline as i've kind
of collected based on what i saw through
the video and what other people have
shown by the way seth by the way seth
this is how you do a timeline this is
how you do research because gabe puts
facts inside of his videos and his
research if you wanna right so what
happened yesterday was he saw the tweet
he shared it now again i i i don't i
don't like the infighting but when
somebody tells 945
000 people to block me i have a little
bit of an issue if you have an issue
with me
send me a dm contact me come on the show
come on
but when you
violate the twitter terms of service
and tell
945 000 people almost 1 million people
that they should block me it's a little
unprofessionally immature and i'll tell
you why because
as a journalist
you should have done the research to
look into this right it was very easy if
you saw it was understood
30 seconds go over to truth social don't
see it boom but unfortunately what you
did was you saw it and now again i don't
know seth but he says he's a trump
biographer and he says he very much
is uh is an expert in the field he's
he's been covering it for the last seven
years
and he was tricked to the extent that he
thought it was real right he believed it
whether he wanted to believe it or he
saw and he goes wow this is
this is written just like him
so i don't know if that says more about
him or about me but
so i mean when you read them enough and
you see the speeches you you kind of it
just becomes second nature again i
hadn't done this in in a few months so
you intended to meet you would send it
to me like what do you think about this
i'm like put a couple exclamation points
in there you need right exactly throw
this you're missing the next question
yeah so what end up happening so i so he
shared it right he didn't he didn't
check it he put it on there yeah seth he
he shared it whether it was from someone
else or me put it up onto his uh he
tweeted it
whatever he said
somebody said hey this might be fake so
we took it down uh-oh at this point you
know he feels probably duped and you
know maybe he feels embarrassed because
he sent it out to nearly a million he's
a journalist and an attorney and a trump
biographer he should exactly
again you know he felt he felt kind of
duped here and whether he was
embarrassed he was like oh look i'm
gonna go check in on this i don't know
again he didn't do the research which i
think says more about him again i don't
know him but i think it says more about
the idea that a journalist wouldn't do
research and look it into it well that's
probably the problem we have in this
country right and so what happened later
on the day
he takes it down he then blocks me which
i didn't even know uh about his account
until people were tweeting at me and
then he sent out a tweet that said you
should
uh or i recommend blocking i am deep
sanchez right he is a threat to
democracy
but doesn't give yeah not an ally
doesn't give any context to who i am or
what this is about which i think was
intentional
because i think that if he would have
shared the image he could have redlined
it he could have been like hey this is
you know he could have he could have
done a daniel dale and threw a big x on
it right
at least daniel at least daniel dale had
the [ __ ] respect exactly
to show your image even with a with a
shitty red x across it because that's
that's typical daniel
yeah if it's like this isn't real i'm
going to do a crazy thread about how
many claps marger taylor green did or
he's going to write an article about
something right whatever it might be
well i want to say why we why we're
invoking daniel dale he's welcome on two
and really yeah honestly daniel and said
you come on at the same time we'll
[ __ ] we'll teach you both how this
works we can talk about it not you know
you know hey
round table keep you guys in check right
and so here's the thing he tweeted it he
told 945 000 people that they should
block me because i was uh not an ally
and i was a threat to i was a danger i
was dangerous to democracy
and so what ended up happening
was he didn't include the image and the
image would have been the actual press
release now i think
in his mind by not including the details
the specifics of what the image was or
what this was about
he thought it would make it seem better
right instead of including the image and
saying hey this is what was shared
because if you think if he did
most people if not all would say well
this is
this is ridiculous maybe some people
some people might agree because there's
gonna be people that are like oh yeah i
don't care for the stuff don't put trump
stuff on this platform we hear it all
the time when people share videos
don't show this stuff even when i
retweet videos like exactly exactly so
he sends a tweet he does this thing and
i'm like yeah it's a little immature and
unprofessional if you had a problem
again reach out to me or you know send
me some other tweet or whatever it is
instead of just hey block this person
because they're a danger
look wouldn't have done it that way
probably a better way to do it you know
he claims in the video that i saw that
he's like it served his purpose so i
closed down the comments i go oh you me
you mean the uh the instagram live yeah
right
yeah he closed the comments because he
watched us on the show right why he
closed the comments and he closed the
comments because the comment section was
full of comments saying you're a [ __ ]
idiot because you're the one you're the
one that didn't check this out you're
supposed to be a journalist you're
supposed to be he he literally he
literally claims to be this great
researcher like the greatest researcher
ever and he has he has just you know a
little bit of a troll farm that yeah
that that claim that thinks he's some
kind of [ __ ] research got or some
[ __ ] and he might be a smart guy he
might be well educated he might be well
read but the problem is is a
[ __ ] doesn't know what uh
what satire is he doesn't know he kept
claiming he knows but seth it really is
very simple i know you have a dictionary
somewhere on that bookshelf that's
behind you that you claim you've read
all those [ __ ] books or whatever
right there's a [ __ ] dictionary back
there someone dust that [ __ ] off
dust it off go to s and look up satire
and see what the [ __ ] it says and then
once you figure out that [ __ ]
definition you can come back to us
because i'll tell you the thing because
i thought it was hilarious what he was
how he was self-destructing right right
but one thing that really pissed me off
yesterday and i showed in my tweet when
i
when i came to your defense and really i
wasn't coming to your defense i was just
trying to stay oh thanks no i'm just
kidding yeah yeah well then why i mean i
was just i was trying to state the fact
right what really pissed me off is when
he claimed that you weren't an ally and
you don't give a [ __ ] about democracy
that's what really [ __ ] pissed me off
about it because ultimately seth
abramson
through our discovery yesterday of who
he is that [ __ ] is more
concentrated he is obsessed with ron
desantis and he is obsessed with 2024
and he is the reason why if we lose as
pro-democracy people
in 2022 he's the reason why because he's
got his [ __ ] people so focused on ron
desantis who is not running for
president right now he's running for
governor yeah he's running for governor
and he's so focused on 2024 that he's
going to miss the ohio race for senate
in ohio he's going to miss the the
senate race in pennsylvania he's going
to miss the one in missouri he's gonna
miss the one in arizona because he's so
[ __ ] [ __ ] focused on an election
cycle that hasn't even started yet right
and this is the reason why it is so
important because he attacked you
and and told almost a million people
well it seems like a million people yeah
yeah to un to block you
because you're not an ally and everyone
on this show and everyone who's who
knows you on twitter and has watched
your content knows that that is the
furthest thing from the [ __ ] truth
and that's really why seth abramson lost
more followers yesterday and you gained
you gained more followers right right
lost which you know and i i just want to
say this like i was not expecting that
as a result i i did not i did not see
that coming you know i certainly wasn't
expecting waking up to a tweet like that
but i i certainly wasn't expecting
anyone to to come to my defense and i
and i truly appreciate and i want to say
thank you to everyone who who uh
explained to him who i was right because
i think what seth did was he just made
the jump and said this image which i
think is the other problem here is he
saw the image saw that i posted it and
then said
this guy is a danger did not look into
who i was did not do the research right
here's the other part too what if i did
not actually create that image what if i
was what if i was sharing it and someone
else shared it and then he said i'm a
danger so he made an assumption while he
was right that we created it he made an
assumption yes he didn't contact us a
journalist a journalist would do their
[ __ ] due diligence when i would
contact someone who they thought was the
[ __ ] owner to verify because gabe and
gabe has never and i know this for sure
for a fact that he has never denied that
he made it that he made a graphic or he
made a video that he made when a
journalist a real a real [ __ ] not
some self-proclaimed journalist but a
real [ __ ] journalist contacted him
and asked me he's given statements to
several [ __ ] articles about previous
statements and if you would have just
did i don't know two three minutes of
research like a journalist should have
done you'd have [ __ ] known that but
one thing one thing i want to do here is
i want to show the audience who the [ __ ]
this guy is and the [ __ ] that he's
disposing and i want to show you why
why he
is [ __ ] hurting the pro democracy
movement and i'm not saying that seth
can't change his mind because i believe
seth can i believe that seth can change
his ways i think he's a smart educated
guy and he can stop this nonsense where
he attacks people who are pro-democracy
and he keeps and he keeps [ __ ]
propping up these right-wing [ __ ]
fascists who were talking about killing
their [ __ ] grandchildren on the house
floor this is we played a video
yesterday at debbie lasko and i don't
have to replay it again everyone's seen
the [ __ ] where she's talking
about guns and protecting her
grandchildren how she's going to shoot
her grandchildren protect them and
here's seth abramson yes yes i got a
sock puppet and i'm i'm trolling the
[ __ ] [ __ ] you i'm doing and i
don't give a [ __ ] this is not a
screenshot this is really twitter here
hahaha seth
block me again [ __ ] okay so um
he tweets out
just yesterday debbie laska oh is an
insurrectionist but i think she sure
almost certainly meant to say
shoot someone quote unquote rather than
shoot them
as her quote makes no logical sense
putting aside moral sense otherwise
listen
seth if you can do mental gymnastics
when debbie lasko has not come out and
said that she meant to say and she
misspoke you [ __ ] if you could
do mental gymnastics to [ __ ] protect
and try to [ __ ] uh scoff away a
united states elected official a
representative from arizona debbie lasko
going to the house floor and putting on
our official record in the house that
she would shoot her grandkids to protect
them with a gun because that's her
prerogative as a grandma
you you would go to the extent of
putting out a tweet like this to protect
her but when there's no evidence none
that debbie lasco the most that she said
was she tweeted out and says oh i can't
believe these gun control zealots you
know thought it would attack me she
never said i misspoke she never said i
didn't mean them i meant to shoot
whoever like
this is something again mary miller not
two weeks ago was on stage and said
thank you trump for protecting white
lives
earlier this year she was on stage
quoting hitler right you know so it's a
moment like this where it's like whether
you call it a gaffe whether you caught
it for freudian slip whatever it was
they meant what they said and they said
what they meant well if it was a problem
they would have corrected and to justify
is is [ __ ] because here's the thing
trying to justify this type of response
be like well they met someone else they
didn't mean shoot them
like we should be giving them the
benefit of doubt no we shouldn't these
are the people that want to control
women's bodies these are the people that
want to unravel same-sex marriage these
are the people that want to give guns to
everyone these are the people that want
to make this country a dangerous place
so to give them an inch and say she
meant someone not them is [ __ ]
[ __ ] and i think again
just like seth was focusing on a very
trivial not important issue and tried to
make it a very big important issue he's
doing the same here he's trying to then
take a very big important issue for a
representative who put it on a [ __ ]
public record to say guys guys it's not
actually that she meant this i don't
care if it was a gaff she said it right
and these are the people who mean what
they say then she then debbie lasko
needs to go to the [ __ ] house floor
and refudiate the record and change the
record
in front of a [ __ ] microphone that's
what she can do and she should do if
this is what she meant but the point i'm
trying to make because everyone in the
thing is saying seth has a sub stack
they're trying to figure out who seth is
because a lot of people don't know who
seth is you've got to be a journalist
yeah right he claims to be a journalist
he claims to be an attorney
self-proclaimed uh journalist the point
is he may be a great researcher and a
great journalist the point is is that
the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
yesterday got butt hurt because he got
tricked by our piece of satire and
gabe's great artwork of making it look
real he got [ __ ] tricked because he
wouldn't take two seconds to check it
because he wanted it to he wanted to
believe that it was real so he's not a
good journalist in my mind and i i well
i welcome self to come on the show and
tell us how he is a good journalist and
i'll tell him how he's not and maybe
maybe just maybe maybe just maybe we can
come to an agreement here because seth
abramson is not a good journalist by
definition based on this statement and
then the exact opposite when he did what
he did with gabe's piece of satire which
everyone knew everyone knew it was a
piece of [ __ ] satin
the other thing too is like you made a
great point earlier it's like when i've
done past pieces of works whether it's
video or written form there's always
someone who comes and reaches out to me
and says hey are you the creator of this
content can i get a quote and i say sure
yeah fine whatever yeah
didn't didn't reuters reuters reached
out to me i had usa today that reached
out to me like other people who have
reached out to me in the past about
previous works whether whatever they
might be
have reached out and said can i get
confirmation
or do you know where this came from i'm
just trying to track it down because you
had daniel dale fact check you he's a
cnn trump fan
and and here's the thing is daniel dale
he
this last time he's like he knew he knew
because
daniel dale knows the gig now yeah yeah
he knows the bit but seth didn't but
but the statements previous he did a
[ __ ] thread he like did a thread of
how he figured out how you yeah i mean
he did his research
gave me
daniel dale spent like an hour like an
hour trying to figure out how to break
it out thank you
now it's ridiculous that daniel jail
would fact check something like that
when he could just contact me and say
hey did you make this is this real yeah
or he could be like this is not real you
look on the you look on truth social
it's not there right so right yeah and
again daniel daniel you're welcome to
come on the show with you and you guys
are welcome i mean like you know i don't
know seth's got to unblock us to come on
the show and talk to us
he had did he on did he unblock you oh
you're saying or you're oh i'm saying
like he would have to if you wanted to
register well he's he's using sackbug
but accounts to stop right but i think i
think the funniest thing is also the
assumption that he made uh beyond the
fact he's like oh this person made it
right and this is the person that isn't
that is responsible he looked at my bio
and said he's bragging about daniel dale
fact-checking him
here's the context that you missed seth
here's the context i was not referring i
didn't here's the thing when i woke up
in the morning i did not know that
daniel dale had made a tweet about me
okay did not know that right until
people were messaging him and dming me
and all this stuff
the thing in the bio that says fact
checked by daniel dale cnn was in
reference to a previous one that i had
made
four months ago so there's the evidence
seth if you would if you're a real
journalist and you're a good one the
evidence was right there right [ __ ]
there in front of your [ __ ] face but
not only that i wasn't bragging i mean
yeah sure it's a badge of honor be like
oh i was fact-checked by these people
that's cool whatever you know
but i wasn't bragging about this
statement right it was something i kept
in my bio from previous from a previous
occasion months ago
so because you len saw daniel dale
retweeted him and saw oh my god he's
he's he's saying that this is a badge of
honor from from daniel dale on this on
this [ __ ] message
no you did not do your research right
all the way did not do it and you made a
lot you made assumptions you were right
that i made it but you made assumptions
that i was bragging about this statement
you made an assumption that it was who i
you know it was me and then you jumped
on the assumption that it was real
instead of doing any sort of research
and then made a tweet and saying you
should all block it now again you could
do whatever you want with your account
but you also violated terms of service i
wouldn't be surprised if someone started
reporting your [ __ ] yeah well i i think
they did but you know that's probably
why you turned off the comments as well
and and again again
i want to reiterate i want to reiterate
i think seth
seth is actually thinks thinks that he
is uh pro-democracy i believe he is
pro-democracy i believe he wants the
best for our democracy i i think he's
got a lot of skewed views on on what he
is and who he is and how it works um
we're all self-proclaimed right now
exactly and i would i would welcome i
would welcome seth on the show if you
wanted to come on i i don't know if he's
watching i'm sure he is under a sock but
again or something like that maybe
that's some of these comments these pro
seth comments that are in the um the
thing i i would imagine i would imagine
if a dude had a million followers and
really liked him i would imagine our
comment section be like tony you're
stuck just stop telling me i am you know
i didn't and
the last thing i'll say is you know i
don't know who seth is i had to read
about him and look into him i read a lot
of stuff that was not favorable right
and i made a thread again it was a
joking thread it was one out of 451
because that's the he's a thread man
anyway there's there's a couple articles
and exposes that cover him
and i was quoting different people from
cnn and wait wait you were quoting
journalists you were quoting articles it
was crazy i know i know i did my
research and i found certain things out
and i was quoting things that he had
said and people said that wasn't almost
like you as a self-proclaimed
satirist are better a better
self-proclaimed journalist than even
seth abramson was for your statement and
the debbie lasco
and i i saw in the video because i
quoted those things and and made those
tweets this little like
joking thread that was like six six
actual quotes and then the last one was
like a gift that was like hope you have
an awesome day right it's [ __ ] joke
he said on the video that i was um i was
saying nasty untrue things
yeah look i'm i'm just quoting the
people that covered the situation that
they're talking about that's all you
want the [ __ ] i'm not making any doubt
you are mean gabe you are very mean
that's the other word that's the other
word you know what the other thing i
noticed before we go because we're
running out of time here and we've we've
already went over it's uh uh the other
thing that i noticed during the
instagram live he kept saying this guy
this guy yeah now when he when he talked
about me he said my name and i was
watching and i i wanted to type i wanted
well because i don't know but i wanted
to type i wanted to type
you can say his [ __ ] name
like you can say his name yeah i wonder
why he claimed he claimed that people
were calling him a racist and [ __ ] which
i don't think he was being a [ __ ]
racist yeah i don't know i mean your
last name sanchez i think he was i think
it was
it was an idiotic move right but it was
really again i think it was immature and
unprofessional to tweet that out right i
think there's better ways to get in
contact right
but
yeah it's i i it's i don't know it's so
i don't know the whole thing is so dumb
and like i'm not fighting with him i
don't care about him
he sent a tweet out to nearly a million
people about me and i responded and he
said that i was saying mean things seth
who sathu they keep saying seth who um
that's a good question that's a good
question and and it would be a question
that we do not continue here um because
today is the last day unless seth wants
to come on the show
this seth who guy wants to come on the
show you're welcome seth you're welcome
to come on the show if you want to be
told that you're a really shitty
journalist especially in this case um
then you're welcome to come on the show
you can come on the show we'll talk to
you we'll talk to you about how bad you
are journalism
maybe tomorrow i don't think so tomorrow
tomorrow's friday tomorrow's friday i'm
on my own we have a special guest on i'm
hoping to get dr rachel bittikoffer on
possibly we're trying to get a time for
her to come on we also have bonehead of
the week everyone knows bone of the week
so watch for the poll now for bone end
of the week um
seth who may or may not end up on i
don't know um so follow us at
tonymichaelspot on twitter do not block
us do not block us follow us if you want
to vote yeah you can also vote on the
youtube channel so don't forget to go
down and hit the subscribe button you
can vote for bone end of the week
tomorrow we will break it down for you
as you know you can also download every
single episode on apple spotify google
your favorite directories
because we are live every single weekend
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central on youtube twitter twitch
and we simulcasted a minus facebook page
but here's the thing we download every
single episode on all the directories
for you
to get it right to your ears
so until tomorrow
from our mouth to your ears surfs up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking